[音楽]
こたといえば何ですかもうみかでしょみか
すよねオレンジカモンうんオレンジノノ
カモン
アでま僕が今年1番お世話になった人と
言ったら間違いなくこの方なんすよああ
LINEでもよろしくお願いし
ますいや絶対いけるでしょ絶対いける
でしょ今回なかなか失敗続きの100個
シリーズでござい
ますみか100個ねま年末スペシャルと
いうことではい今回ガチで食いますから体
がいかに黄色くなるかってとこがねま
ポイントですねなんか生き込みを一言
どうぞいやこんなね果物俺からでは行き
ましょうスタートします
スタートい個ねそうす
ねおいおいじゃいただきますむくの早くね
えうまいただきます甘い甘いうん甘いすか
この甘さの
[音楽]
中見せてあげて
くださいえ予備がある予備が見せて
くださいびなんですけどえ食べますよねえ
あの開けたらカが生ってたの
で食べてえカ生えてさ食べないしょい食べ
ますよ普通食べないよカ生えてんだぜ
もったいないっすよえでもカ生えてじゃ
食べるうわほらほら今10個目ですまだ
全然いけますねうん最初のスピード早い
からお行けるんじゃねって思ったけどちょ
ちょっとあうんちょっとちょ嫌あの嫌信号
見えてこ途からくきが怪しくなりますよね
まだ始まったばっかりだ
[音楽]
よキャルソネの場合なん体の構造が別
らしくて背中の方になんか熱うん熱を発散
するなんとかっていうのがあっても
エヴァンゲリオンじゃ
ない20個
目はめくがってるはめくがってる動画
アップしてるんでアップロードできないと
誰も見ないんすよそういうこと
アップロードはYouTuberにとって
大事な儀式の1つそれがなくては何も
始まらないん
です早くやれやあごめん
なさい25個目折り返しではありません
1/4を終わりまし
[音楽]
た
ちょっと目にミカの汁入れてみていいです
かダちょっとだけやだお願ちょっといや
小学小学ちょっとだちょっとだけしよ
ちょっと開け
[音楽]
て
42いいよちょっと食べて休憩俺ずるい
ずるいず休憩ずるいよず休憩してた
じゃんはい1時間経過して今一43分なん
です
けどかなりやばいですなんかこうまで特有
の何食べすぎたらものすごく口に入れるの
をためらっちゃう感じ分かります
[音楽]
分かる
わか50折り返しです折り返しだよいや
まさかのねいやもう限界すよてるよね結構
やばいっす
[音楽]
[拍手]
よ38
個はいというわけで残り38個なんです
けどすいませんここまでにしたいと思い
ますいやまだ行き
[音楽]
[拍手]
るっしょ